do you think that GZ Trump gets a bad
rap I think sometimes I think they like
the guy they give him credit for nothing
he does something good and they won't
give him credit for anything then we'll
give him credit for anything yeah
who's they the public they decided they
don't like him and they kind of spin it
on them
I mean the economy's doing great we got
what all time low african-american
unemployment all-time low
Latino 50 or 60 year low unemployment
the Dow is gonna hit 30 before election
I mean I just I mean I I consider myself
independent I would want to work both
both sides because I think and I think
[ __ ] if you agree with everyone in the
room you're in the wrong room
there should be opposition but you got
to come to an agreement right now it
just seems like it's no nope no no no
button and I mean it goes on both sides
they do that they both with the same
[ __ ] yeah they're kind of getting Obama
with that back then too even the Supreme
Court nominee they didn't even take the
vote or something they do that stuff
needs to be term limits
yeah and I'm convinced they're like it's
not it's not the fault
like the deficit is the problem is not
the person who's in the White House for
eight years it's the person who's in the
Capitol for 40 right you know that's the
issue right and they you know I don't
know I get so pissed off sometimes
talking to my phone at 6:00 I think
everyone does that's what's great yeah
we can all scream at each other
immediately yeah oh yeah yeah Twitter to
me is fun I mean I say should joy it I I
it's an entertainment I'm rarely serious
it's our people shitty people aren't
shady to you oh yeah oh yeah sure
well you know who know gets mad at me is
a lot of the right-wing guys because
they refuse to admit Obama was
responsible for the bin Laden raid and
they yelled like such a pitcher or
didn't happen it's like [ __ ] you hey I
said goodbye to my kids and I thought I
was gonna die it happened yeah I crazy
that they don't want to give him credit
for making the call and it's like it
would have failed who he would he got
blamed Oh course yesterday he rewrote I
mean speaking of politics he rolled the
dice he we fail that he doesn't get
reelected but isn't it it's more
important to get bin Laden but I mean
that's a reality like he's rolling dice
on his own I was that in his first term
no no yeah I think so wasn't I don't
remember she's 11 11 yeah isn't it crazy
that I'm sure then you're getting it
from all sides if you're if you're
willing to say well I think Trump has
done a lot of good and then you're also
willing to say you know Obama was
responsible for this and he did good
when you
president - yeah you have you don't have
both sides supporting you no never both
sides hey I can I could be talking about
the snowfall in my hometown of Butte
Montana within two lines are fighting
about Trump yeah every answer every
tweet it's just I mean to me I I enjoy
it and I'll make headlines sometimes a
stupid [ __ ] that I say it's like wow I
didn't didn't mean that did you eat with
Obama or just talk to him just talk to
him
that was just a great day because
everyone was everyone was on the same
sheet yeah really cool
yeah we just hung out for a little bit
he snuck in he snuck us in so he good
we're at Fort Campbell in in Kentucky
and he was gonna go see the hundred
first airborne so he came in to see us
it was kind of a little head fake they
didn't know we're there then he came out
and saw the saw the troops so it's
always neat meeting a president though
it is I'm sure you met - I've met bush I
met that woman and I'm in Trump since 3
president Trump actually he showed me
the the Lincoln Bedroom and the White
House was pretty cool is that now that's
obviously where Lincoln slept but do
people not get to go in there
well that was a funny story cuz we
walked in and there's the bed that
actually Abe Lincoln's son died in and
he slept in and Abe Lincoln's desk was
there and then towards the South Lawn is
another desk and underneath the glass is
the Gettysburg Address written and
signed by Abe Lincoln so I'm in there
having this out-of-body experience and I
look back in Trump's leaned against the
wall and he said you know not everybody
gets to see this unless of course you
donate to the Clinton Foundation one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM